Um, so we've been really interested in targeting the 9P amplicon, and as everyone knows, this
leads to upregulation of PD-L1 and 2.
It also leads to upregulation of JAK1 and 2, which then also contributes to PD-L1 and
2 expression.
So it's kind of like a positive feedback loop within the 9P amplicon, and this leads to
both increased proliferation and immune evasion.
And as you know, 9P is amplified, you know, hallmark in Hodgkin lymphoma, highly in primary
mediastinal, and a little less so in the pre-surgery cell lymphoma.
Very closely accompanying 9P amplification is rearrangements in 16P, and this leads to
loss of CT2A, which leads to decreased MHC expression, and then further sort of allows
for an immune privilege phenotype.
So we're interested in trying to sort of...
target both of these derangements.
This work was led by one of my mentees, Siddharth Tolu, who's now an assistant professor at
Columbia University, and her hypothesis was that perhaps dual targeting of 9P amplicon
with JAK/SAT inhibitor ruxolitinib and immune checkpoint blockade pembrolizumab will
enhance immunogenicity, modulate lymphomagenesis, and induce cell death.
So we looked at JAK inhibition across...
a panel of lymphoma cell lines enriched in 9P amplification, found that there was a nice
viability curve, cytotoxicity curve, and that there was a little bit more sensitivity in the
9P amplified lymphomas.
We looked at drivers of immunogenicity and cell growth and found that ruxolitinib led to
increased CT2A expression, decreased PD-L1 and 2 expression, and decreased MYC expression.
And these were most pronounced in those with a sort of higher 9P amplification.
Looking at RNA sequencing, we found a number of modulated genes, and specifically we found decreased
stat RNA sequencing, decreased MYC, and also decreased PD-L1 and 2.
We also found that there was increased MHC-2 expression across the board, more or less.
And looking at the profiles, we found that they were upregulated genes in lymphocyte differentiation,
immune response, as well as response to type 1 interferon.
And so with that, we were interested in looking at what was going on in the peripheral milieu.
So we collected peripheral blood from Hodgkin and primary mediastinal patients,
treated them ex vivo with ruxolitinib, and also pembrolizumab and the combination,
and found that we were able to increase, so these are blood without any lymphoma within them,
or are curious what was happening in the peripheral blood, and found that it increased
encased T cells, decreased Tregs, and decreased PD-L1 expression in both CD4 and CD8 T cells.
We then decided to create...
We then decided to create lymphoma organoids or spheroids using a 9P amplified cell lines.
Then we co-cultured these with healthy CD8 T cells, and we exposed them to both ruxolitinib,
pembrolizumab, or the combination, to see how these impacted both cell kill and T cell infiltration.
And so looking first just at these organoids or spheroids treated with ruxolitinib alone,
hopefully it projects somewhat okay, but in the...
The green are the live lymphoma cells, and the red represents the dead cells,
and you can see sort of like a dose response with ruxolitinib, and you can really see in the 2.5
microliter, micromolar concentration that there's really increased cell kill with ruxolitinib.
Then when we add T cells, we don't really see that much of a change,
but when we pretreat T cells with pembrolizumab and the organoids with ruxolitinib, we find that
there's really robust cell kill.
We then wanted to see how T cells were infiltrating within the organoid, and so this is...
Here, the green, again, is the live cells, and the purple is the CD3 positive T cells.
And we found when we added pembrolizumab to the T cells, you see, you know, nice infiltration
to the organoid, but when we combine this with ruxolitinib, we really see intense infiltration
of the spheroid.
So again, we wanted to see how T cells were infiltrating within the organoid, and so this is
we wanted to look what was happening in vivo.
We used partially matched humanized mouse and grafted with carpus, a 9P amplified lymphoma cell
line, and we found in mice treated, in the peripheral blood, again, in the combination,
there was reduced Tregs, increased activation of CD4 cells, CD4 T cells with CD4 ligand and CD69.
We looked also in an immune...
A competent mouse model engrafted with a lymphoma mouse cell line, and again, after treatment
with the combination, we found, again, decreased Tregs, also decreased MDSCs and increased
NK cells.
We found increased activation of CD4 T cells with CD25 and CD44, and decreased exhaustion
with decreased LAG3 and decreased PD-L1, and similar findings in the CD8 T cell population.
When we combined ruxolitinib and pembrolizumab in this immune-competent mouse model, we found
really prolonged overall survival and decreased growth with the combination.
So using the humanized mouse, we performed single-cell RNA sequencing to try to get a
better idea of what was going on within the tumor microenvironment.
We were able to detect different types of cell types within the tumor, sort of different
B-cell cell types.
We were able to detect different types of cell types as well as stromal cells and T-cells.
And we found this a little small, but we found that there was really increased T-cell infiltration
with pembrolizumab and perhaps as well with the combination.
And interestingly, the tumor had decreased MDSCs, increased activation of CD3-positive
T cells within the tumor compartment.
So sometimes we think of ruxolitinib as perhaps a way to reduce CD3-positive T cells, but
it's not.
It's not.
Here we found that in certain types of contacts, ruxolitinib can increase immunogenicity
in lymphoma cells by increasing the CT2A and MHC2 and suppress PD-L1 and 2.
It decreased MYC-driven growth and it primed peripheral blood for increased NK cells,
decreased Tregs, and decreased MDSCs.
The combination enhanced organoid apoptosis and T cell infiltration, and it modulated
the tumor microenvironment with increased T cell activation in vivo.
The combination also led to prolonged survival in mice.
So with that, we've developed a clinical trial, which is now open, and we're hoping
to open it at collaborating sites.
Some of the folks are here.
There has been a clinical study looking at Ruxo plus Nevo and Hodgkin lymphoma.
So we only have really an exploratory arm.
In that cohort, really to try to look at this biology, we're staggering ruxolitinib
and pembrolizumab and collecting samples along the way to try to better understand what's
happening in the peripheral blood, as well as in the tumors.
And then given our interest in sort of these pathways in T cell lymphomas, there's been
a lot of interest in Jaxa inhibition in T cell lymphoma, as well as immune checkpoint
blockade.
We have two cohorts in both nodal PTCL and CTCL.
And in the CTCL patients, we're collecting paired samples along the way in the skin.
So we'll be really excited to see what's happening in the tumor microenvironment there.
So with that, I thank you for listening and really want to acknowledge Sadat Tolu, who
did the bulk of this work, and Ted Prochinski in my lab, our clinical team, and our grand
support and collaborators.
Thank you.